[Music]
mr. Milgram were you diagnosed with
schizophrenia ten years ago a normal
life that's all I want
now what's normal anyway why are you
here I am depressed and I happen for a
very long time
I believe in this treatment and I
believe that we can all be fixed and
help sound Steven
that doesn't sound stupid to me
did I find you
where you supposed to find me
there's my my separating they just find
their way back together maybe these two
have a cosmic connection they were just
two people
looking out for each other
you
do you know where you are right now I'm
in a drug trial what do you think is
wrong with you I'm sick I don't matter
what would you say this trial is showing
you about yourself is this therapy now
it's not therapy it's science
[Music]
once you begin to appreciate the
structure of the mind there's no reason
to believe that anything about us can't
be changed pain can be destroyed the
mind can be solved how many of your
subjects have ended up catatonic roughly
my head doesn't work right I thought
maybe these people can fix me sounds
stupid
that doesn't sound stupid to me okay
people let's begin
my mind is playing tricks
[Music]
[Applause]
some multi reality brain magic [ __ ]
I don't know what's real and what's not
[Music]
something's wrong what did you do every
time I separate them they just find
their way back together
not protecting those people in there
[Music]
you